it's day 61 it's late i drove my  son and his family to the airport  they're going to bali  and i did a bit of uh kim jung-ha again  today uh it's quite interesting he  talked about how he writes books he  talked about  david's  oil painting of the death of maha  which led me to do some research on the  french revolution which reminded me that  revolutions are messy affairs and we  have a revolution occurring right now in  ukraine and  obviously the defenders of the asean  regime in neighboring countries or one  specific country are quite perturbed at  this revolution  and i hope this revolution will be able  to defend itself we will see what  happens anyway i'm going to bed bye